papa
wirst du mich später zum schwimmbad
fahren
ich habe mit louis und ronja abgemacht
sicher
aber zuerst muss du noch
ein zimmer aufräumen
aber zuerst muss du noch dein zimmer
aufräumen
ja das werde ich später machen
ich habe noch genug zeit
glaubst du dass es in der zukunft
roboter geben wird die unsere
hausarbeiten machen werden
glaubst du dass es in der zukunft
roboter geben wird die unsere
hausarbeiten machen werden
ja das wird sicher möglich sein
aber nicht alle leute werden sich einen
roboter leisten können
werden die leute auf dem mond
urlaub machen
vielleicht ich würde aber lieber ans
meer fahren oder in die berge gehen
aber auf dem mond wird es sicher lustig
sein
sie werden dort aliens sehen und wir
werden auf die erde schauen können
sie werden dort aliens sehen
wir werden auf die erde schauen können
das stimmt aber der preis für einen
mondflug wird sehr teuer sein
nur wenige menschen werden sich urlaub
auf dem mond leisten können
papa denkst du dass du in der zukunft
nicht mehr arbeiten werden muss
warum werde ich nicht mehr arbeiten
müssen
irgendjemand muss auch in der zukunft
geld verdienen
ich werde in der zukunft arbeiten gehen
und du wirst dein zimmer aufräumen
müssen
ich werde in der zukunft arbeiten gehen
und du wirst dein zimmer aufräumen
müssen
und wer wird dich dann zum schwimmbad
fahren
in der zukunft hätte es sicher
selbstfahrende autos geben
in der zukunft wird es sicher
die wird man ganz einfach auf dem handy
bestellen können wie die ubl
ich frage mich ob es überhaupt eine
zukunft geben wird
so wie wir die umwelt verschmutzen wird
die menschheit große probleme bekommen
wir werden kein sauberes trinkwasser
mehr haben
[Musik]
die luft wird schmutzig sein
und es wird mehr
strafen geben wie wirbelstürme
hitzewellen überschwemmungen und so
weiter
und es wird mehr naturkatastrophen
die wirbelstürme hitzewellen
überschwemmungen usw
wir haben das auch in der schule
diskutiert
wir müssen alternative energien fördern
zb solarenergie oder windenergie
und wir müssen unser abwasser nicht in
die flüsse und meere leiten sondern
zuerst reinigen
und wir müssen unser abwasser nicht in
die flüsse und meere leiten sondern
zuerst reinigen
und vor allem sollen wir nicht mehr
fliegen und recyceln
da hast du dich
träumen jetzt dein zimmer auf
und dann bleibt noch genug zeit dass du
mit dem fahrrad zum schwimmbad fahren
kannst
rom jetzt dein zimmer auf
und dann bleibt noch genug zeit dass du
mit dem fahrrad zum schwimmbad fahren
kannst
so kannst du gleich etwas für die umwelt
machen
ich muss jetzt weiter ab
[Musik]
ich muss jetzt weiter arbeiten
abonniere die halo deutsch schule auch
auf instagram oder facebook abonniere
die halo deutsche schule auch auf
instagram oder facebook möchtest du
gratis online deutsch lernen mehr als
200 video lektionen abonniere unseren
kanal möchtest du gratis online deutsch
lernen mehr als 200 video lektionen
abonniere unseren kanal